oui ça va mon maths tu es en forme qui
est bien
la tournée des 20 ans samedi dernier tu
étais à la défense Arena ta rassemblé
plus de 25000 personnes c'est la
première fois
on a des images regardez la guerre la
guerre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la tournée des bateaux M Pokora
nous on lourd
très très très fort alors est-ce que tu
peux nous dire parce que tu vas
reprendre tu as tellement de titres de
son maintenant de tube je dors c'est un
truc de fou et comment tu as fait pour
choisir parce que c'est dur hein
justement c'était la cette liste la plus
compliquée à faire pour moi parce que
j'ai aussi un nouvel album j'aime
toujours mettre aussi
mais donc du coup c'est c'est la
première tournée où vraiment le nouvel
album a vraiment pas beaucoup de place
tu fais combien de son du nouvel album
je crois 5 5 et tout le reste c'est ben
elle me contrôle pas sans toi photos de
toi
mettez-nous un peu là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
laissez-moi une photo de toi
c'est juste une photo de toi je suis
pote de toi tout ce qui me nourritent
une photo de toi juste une photo de toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mettez-moi des trucs là mettez-moi tout
mettez moi tout là j'ai envie
c'est bien ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autour de toi je ne veux plus que le
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dadju aussi très fort très fort
mettez-moi tout la mettez-moi tout
[Musique]
ça là
vous les avez préparé avant vous êtes
avec un pick-up à l'ancienne sur la tête
de ma mère j'ai l'impression
vous débarquez les gars non je suis à
deux doigt de venir en rigide vous
défoncez
les planètes
il doit faire il va faire il va nous
faire des sons va nous faire un kiff
donc je vous le dis vous allez donner un
petit billet à moi
je vais voir ce que je vais lui redonner
d'accord donc là tu vas voir ok pour
l'instant venez monsieur venez ça va tu
ici
comment ça va comment tu t'appelles
[Applaudissements]
bon bah allez c'est parti
vous avez de la voix tout le monde a de
la voix là
ok c'est parti elle me contrôle
[Musique]
si elle me frotte je ne répondrai pour
plus de moi sur la dancehall écoute ma
voix si tu me frôles alors je ne
répondrai plus de moi
vous connaissez juste une photo de toi
avec moi ça fait comme ça j'ai cœur en
braqué si je dérape c'est parce que t'es
pas pris aussi vite que t'es arrivé tu
t'en es allé avec un bout de moi
tout ce
qui
de toi juste une photo de toi juste une
photo de toi tu sais que tu laisses
c'est juste une photo de toi je suis une
photo de toi juste une photo de toi là
là là là là là
là
là là là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
OK
et ça fait
un choc je pense à toi de shot je pense
à toi
trois chats je pense à toi
quand je danse quand tu dors
[Applaudissements]
tout tout tout
pardonne-moi
mon indiff
je reviendrai
lever du jour qui tape au contre ma peau
laisse ta peau contre moi pour laisse
moi donner le tempo
contre ma peau c'est un faux contre ma
poule de peau contre ma peau laisse moi
godet
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on s'aime est-ce qu'on
s'oublie et un petit tombé OK
[Musique]
on se perdra c'est sûr mais jamais
longtemps on se retrouve à je suis sûr
comme un jeu d'enfant on se perdra pour
ceux mais avec le temps cet homme race
c'est sûr un jour je t'entends et je
suis tombé tomber danser je suis touché
bravo marraine tu as gagné je ne suis
qu'un fou un fou
enfermé je suis tombé
je suis tombé avec moi ça fait comment
je suis ton
c'est ça je suis touché
un fou
je suis tombé
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
beaucoup merci et franchement merci
bravo bravo merci beaucoup merci merci
[Applaudissements]
plus de 5 millions de disques vendus 20
ans de carrière si tourner une comédie
musicale plus de 3 millions de
spectateurs neuf albums studios 3 albums
live un disque de diamant 3 double
disque de platine un triple disque de
platine un CD DVD disque d'or un
recordman d'énergie Music Awards avec 14
trophées
c'est le Djokovic
c'est le choco
c'est le Joko c'est notre Dogo
sur scène c'est le plus gros showman
français vraiment et je peux vous dire
mais vraiment de loin voilà il est
incroyable mat et c'est un bosseur de
fou et c'est pour ça que ça fait 20 ans
qu'il est toujours il est toujours en
haut bravo mon chéri je suis très fier
de toi et vraiment tu déchires tu
déchires mon frérot vraiment
20 ans
il y a Lionel Stan le directeur général
directeur général H2O qui me parlait de
toi avant parce qu'il était il était sur
popstar à l'époque et il m'avait dit
j'ai vu Matt j'ai dit c'est une énorme
star et je lui ai dit tu vois tu étais
pas trompé tu vois et surtout fallait le
voir le petit gringalé
quand même non mais en tout cas c'est
c'est énorme alors je voudrais qu'on
voit encore des images parce que de la
tournée le teaser de la tournée c'est
énorme franchement c'est énorme il y a
combien de danseurs avec toi combien il
y a 14
danseurs les musiciens on est une
vingtaine sur scène et puis après les
effets pyrotechnique un écran de 45
mètres de large 8 mètres d'eau des
Lumières à main plus finir et on est à
un moment on est un peu plus d'une
centaine à bosser sur
lui dans son salon
l'écran regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
juste une photo
de toi
[Applaudissements]
que toi et moi je ne veux plus que le
monde
tourne autour de toi
contre ma peau laisse la pauvre Mamour
[Musique]
en tournée dans toute la France et puis
s'entretour la tournée des 20 ans le
match
et il y a l'album qui cartonne épicentre
hein bien sûr on va voir un nouveau
single qui s'appelle parce que c'est toi
c'est la première fois qu'il est diffusé
en télé regardez et vous le savez ici
tous les chroniqueurs c'est pas parce
que c'est mon pote je connais
pratiquement toutes ces chansons par
cœur donc c'est pas du mytho il l'a vu
voilà je kiffe vraiment c'est à dire que
même si je le connaissais pas je kiffe
ces sons bah là c'est parce que c'est
toi
Daniel c'est pour toi
[Musique]
et nous voici une gueule de maths
que j'avais gardé
comme surprise ce soir je l'ai pas
annoncé ce week-end etc je voulais
garder une petite exclu c'est que on a
pris la décision de rajouter une date à
Paris le 19 décembre
tout ça là
alors ça tombe bien
ça tombe bien parce que ma mère m'a dit
j'ai pas eu de place pour Mathieu je te
jure que c'est vrai il va m'envoyer ça
il y a un instant mais elle ira le 19
décembre le 19 décembre et on ouvre la
billetterie ce vendredi à 10h alors tu
mets 4 places
directs sur la tête de ménagement c'est
pour ma mère non franchement sur ma vie
c'est vrai non parce qu'elle je te jure
qu'elle vient de m'envoyer elle m'a dit
pourquoi on n'a pas été voir Matt elle
m'a expliqué donc 19 décembre date
supplémentaire le 19 je vais la nuit
mardi soir c'est bon je vais même
annuler TPMP
ça coûtera moins cher c'est comme ça tu
sais je vais te dire j'en ai rien à
alors et ce matin je suis tombé
sur un truc une rigolade il devait être
7h20 du matin je commence à travailler à
4h30 parce que j'ai les premières
fournée première fougasse et je suis
tombé sur une vidéo après ce sont des
enfants coréens qui devaient deviner le
métier de personnalité française et dans
les photos qui étaient montré il y avait
Matt et il y avait moi je crois que
c'est vrai c'est énorme et regarde ce
qu'on leur inspire c'est un délire
regarde
cette personne je dirais un chanteur un
humoriste un employé chanteur moi je dis
chanteur oui sinon mannequin c'est un
montagnard on peut voir que c'est un
homme tatoué
c'est une racaille non je pense pas que
ce soit une racaille à mon avis c'est
soit un policier ou un pêcheur
[Applaudissements]
c'est un pêcheur non mais franchement
c'est pas force cette vidéo on est tombé
sur ça avec les équipes ce matin c'est
incroyable c'est pas truqué c'est vrai
c'est magnifique ils ont montré des
personnalités françaises à des enfants
coréens et voilà il devait dire ce qu'on
leur inspiré moi j'ai kiffé quand même
mannequin je vais partir en coréen
j'adore